the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another a song of ice and fire
video
alright my friends i have another update
for you this update is from george rr
martin himself
about the winds of winter as you all
know george r martin is still writing
the winds of winter
the next book and has a song of ice and
fire saga
this is a book he has been writing for
nearly a decade
and honestly it might even be longer
than that who knows when he wrote his
first chapter for this book
all i know is this is something not only
the fans have been waiting for
but hbo has been waiting for this as
well as you all know this book should
have been released before game of
thrones ended but we all know
that never happened that was very
unfortunate
but it is what it is we all just have to
keep moving forward
well it sounds like that's exactly what
george has done
earlier this morning george gave us
another update on his not a blog website
he started things off by mentioning how
bad last year was
not only because of the lockdowns but
also because he lost many friends
i do feel bad about that because i had
lost several friends last year as well
it sucks it really does as bad as last
year was
he still did manage to get some good out
of it let me show you what he had to say
he said what was good about 2020 besides
the election
well for me there was work i wrote
hundreds and hundreds of pages of the
winds of winter
the best year i've had on winds of
winner since i began it
now that really is great news why did he
have so much success writing the book
last year well he doesn't know
maybe the isolation or maybe i just got
on a roll
sometimes i do get on a roll i need to
keep rolling though
i still have hundreds of more pages to
write to bring the novel to a
satisfactory conclusion
that's what this year is for i hope i
will make no predictions on when i will
finish
every time i do a-holes on the internet
take that as a promise
and then wait eagerly to crucify me when
i miss the deadline
all i will say is that i am hopeful i
have a zillion other things to do as
well though
every time i wrap up one thing three
more things land on me
monkeys on my back a.a i've sung that
song before
so many monkeys and kong but that is
something he will discuss on a later
date
he finishes it up by saying meanwhile
guys and gals
keep yourself safe and healthy i will
try to do the same
well i believe it was the isolation that
helped him the most
it's hard to get distracted by a lot of
other things when you really can't leave
the house
now there was one thing i found very
interesting about this update
for those of you who have followed
george over the years or even if you
have only seen my ones of winter update
videos
you would know that he is the master of
not revealing too much information
he did reveal something in this update
though he sort of revealed how much more
he has to write before he's finished
he said he wrote hundreds and hundreds
of pages last year
but he still needs to write a few
hundred more in order to bring the book
to a satisfactory conclusion
now assuming that's an accurate
estimation we can make a guess at how
much longer it will take for him to
finish it
based on what he said in the update he
is able to write hundreds of pages in
one year
if it's a great year of writing which it
doesn't seem like that happens very
often
otherwise the book would already be done
since he still has a few hundred pages
to go
it might take him another year or even
longer if it's not a very good year for
him
this is the ones of winner though and we
all know how many times it was delayed
so i won't go holding my breath waiting
for the book i still think this is
exciting news
hopefully george is able to ride the
momentum right into this year
hopefully he has another great year
where he can write as much as he did
last year
if he's able to do that then he should
be done this is like his fourth update
in six months so i would like to think
he's happy with where he's at right now
he must be in a good headspace since he
keeps mentioning it every so often
but then again who knows let me know
what you think about this new update
leave your thoughts down below now
before i go i just want to let everyone
know
i did upload another update video a few
hours ago
i've actually uploaded several videos
since yesterday so i'm not sure how many
of you have seen all of them
there was another house of the dragon
update and i think most of you will like
the move hbo made
for those of you who haven't seen my
last video i will show you that now
so you can stay up to date if you
already saw that video then feel free to
end this one now
either way thank you for watching have a
great day
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another house of the dragon
update video
well my friends i have some really great
news for all you game of thrones and
house of the dragon fans
the emmy award-winning game of thrones
composer raymond d jawadi
will return to score house of the dragon
this is the man who is responsible for
giving game of thrones
its amazing and distinctive sound
honestly
this is the best news i've heard since
it was announced miguel sapochnick would
be involved with house of the dragon
hbo has not only brought back their best
director for game of thrones but they're
also bringing back the man who gave us
one of the best scores television has
ever seen
or heard for that matter this has me
very excited because his score will
instantly take house of the dragon to
the next level the article goes on to
say
composer raymond d jawadi who rose to
fame thanks to his indelible score on
the hbo hit series game of thrones
will return for the network's coming
prequel series house of the dragon
both of the game of thrones blog sites
notice dee jawadi's updated resume
on his agency's website included the
pilot episode for house of the dragon
among his television score work
d jawadi has won several emmys and he
has been nominated
seven times for outstanding music
composition
his back-to-back wins came in 2018 in
2019 for game of thrones
i believe he won emmys for his work on
game of thrones season 7
and game of thrones season 8. i'm
actually surprised he did not win
anything for his work on the season 6
finale the wins of winner
because in my opinion light of the 7 is
hands down some of his best work
movie and television fans are also
likely familiar with dee jawed's work on
hbo's other hit drama westworld he's
also the composer behind the iron man
movie score
the 46 year old musician got his start
in hollywood score composing after
working with the legendary han zimmer
you know i had a really good feeling hbo
would bring him back
after they brought back miguel
sapochnick now we all knew megusa
pochnik was a good director after he did
hardhome
but his name wasn't on everyone's radar
until he directed the final episodes of
season 6
the battle of the bastards and the winds
of winter i think after he did those
episodes a lot of fans went to social
media
saying they wanted miguel to direct more
episodes for the remaining seasons
i believe this is one of the main
reasons hbo did bring him back for the
final season
as well as making him a show runner on
house of the dragon
he was a fan favorite just like raymond
d jawadi
hbo is well aware of what the fans want
even if they don't always give it to us
signing these guys on for house of the
dragon brings them one step closer to
making the show a success
so i just want to give a shout out to
hbo for making the move
you did the right thing here thank you i
think that's all i have for right now
i just wanted to make a quick update
video as always
i will see you again whenever something
else is announced
make sure you subscribe if you want to
stay up to date on all the information
regarding house of the dragon
or any of the other shows hbo has in
development
once again thank you all for stopping by
to check out the video i hope everyone
has a great day
i will see you again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
you